[Music]
the number of threats against federal
judges has surged in recent years
jumping
380 percent from 2015 to 2019. think
about that for just one second
that's according to the us marshals
service which protects judges
and judicial facilities last summer u.s
district court
judge esther salas is her name was
targeted by a lawyer
with a grudge against her he showed up
at her home
shot and killed her 20 year old son on
last night's 60 minutes judge salas
discussed a chilling discovery that
investigators made
after the attack he knew
where obviously where i lived he knew my
routes to work
he knew the church we attended he
had daniel's school he knew baseball
games
just a complete work up on me and my
family the information that he got
all from legal sources all open source
as they call it
60 minutes reveal that the gunman also
targeted supreme court justice sonia
sotomayor
since her son's death judge salas has
been pushing for legislation that would
protect judges and make it harder to get
private information
about them she joins us now this morning
good morning to you jud sales i don't
even know where to begin we all watch
the 60 minutes piece
we're all marveling at your strength and
your courage this morning listen
you're in a conversation with your son
the doorbell rings he goes to answer it
and your life is forever
changed forever forever good morning
to you ms king and thank you for having
me this morning yeah
all of our hearts go out yeah it's
forever yeah
thank you thank you so much my husband
is recovering at home he had major
surgery on february 11th
and i am you know we are both just
trying
uh to pick back the pieces of our
shattered lives and um
we're doing all that we can to make sure
this never happens
to anyone else yes yes bless you for
that we know that your husband was also
injured i was going to ask you how he
was doing
but before this july attack this
happened in july 2020
it's your son's birthday that day and i
love how you all were talking and the
doorbell rings he goes mom i love
talking he runs up and answers the door
before that day did you ever think that
your job was dangerous
you know you always know there's a
certain amount of uh
danger that goes into into the job um
and we were cognizant of that uh but
uh i don't um i think covid
and the pandemic we sort of let our
guards down
a bit because of all the packages that
were being delivered
and things that were coming to the house
so you know you do know but i don't
think i understood
how much open source information is
available
and how that information can be used to
target us
and to literally gun us down yeah and
you don't think judge that they're going
to come to your home you certainly don't
think that
you know there it was revealed on the
attack of the capital that when they
found some of the documentation that
some of the
rioters had that they also had the name
of a judge that they were targeting
and we said in the lead to this piece
the threats have gone up
close to 400 percent why do you think
that is happening now
you know you know i think there are a
myriad of reasons why it's happening but
i always like to say it's happening
we know it's happening the attack on my
family
the attack on all the judges nationwide
isn't just an attack on us it's an it's
an attack
of against the united states of america
the bedrock of our democracy is the
judicial system
and and these attacks are really
uh jeopardizing the integrity of law
and what this country was founded on and
i think that we need to do something and
we need to do something now
judge it's anthony mason you are now
under constant protection by the u.s
marshals service
what is your life like now
you know my life since july 19th um
it's it's it's been a whirlwind uh
my husband and i are forever changed
sadly
daniel was our only son uh we tried
desperately to have him
we you know in total lost four um
pregnancies and and i had four
miscarriages better said and
uh he was our miracle baby and um
you know not having him in our lives
anymore is
is probably the worst thing that could
happen to any parent
and that's why i am on this mission i am
on this mission
to ensure that something is done by the
leaders of this country
and i am again begging them to do
something and to do something now to
change
to enforce our laws to better protect
the
members of the bench my brothers and
sisters as i like to call them
we need to do something we need to act
now not tomorrow
today is now is the time
i think every day that we allow uh it to
go by without taking
action is a day that we are in essence
failing the judiciary and
failing the members that that serve on
the bench
um i i do hope uh that that something is
done
to uh increase security for judges and
there is a common sense approach in this
bill it will
take immediate concrete actions to
protect judges
it will do something to you know protect
us
and i i quite frankly believe that it is
uh something that must be done now
you know we have less than a minute left
but i do want to know about your son
honestly i can't stop thinking about him
what was your last conversation i saw a
piece
where his friends were saying what a
great young man he was
what do you want us to know about him
i want everyone to know that daniel is
was love daniel loved his friends he
loved his family
he loved life and i know that daniel's
looking down and saying
you know mom keep it going keep the
fight up
um and and i hope that i make him proud
and and i hope that uh his legacy will
live on
with the daniel anderl uh judicial
security and privacy act
yes you're making him proud you're
making us all proud judge salas judge
salus thank you so much everyone should
watch that 60 minute story to understand
what this is all about and again as gail
said we we greatly admire your strength
judge thank you so much for being with
us
you're watching cbs this morning we'll
be right back